because it's just right all the time
just right that sounds like the Outback
Steakhouse hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
Reason TV and today we're talking with
Arthur C Brooks who's the president of
the American Enterprise Institute and
the author of the new book the battle
how the fight between free enterprise
and big government will shape America's
future Arthur thanks for joining us
thank you open the book with a chapter
about the 7030 nation what what is the
7030 nation the 7030 nation is is all
about the contours and public opinion
between the people who like the free
enterprise system culturally and the
people who reject the free enterprise
system culturally so one of the things
that you find is that most Americans
don't see free enterprise is of just an
economic matter they see it as kind of a
lifestyle issue they see it as the
bedrock of American culture and that's
about 70 percent of the population you
go out there and you ask people do you
believe that the free markets are the
best way to organize our economy despite
severe ups and downs 7 and 10 say yes
about 20 percent say no and 10 percent
evidently don't understand the question
who were who are the people who don't
the 30 percent who are the people who
don't like free enterprise and what
formed or and actually let's take it
back to define free enterprise well free
enterprise is that I mean they're it's
it's the manifestation of the freedoms
that our founders talked about so our
founders talked about making the freest
nation in the world and how do you you
have to express that in some way in a
way that we expressed that in our work a
day world is a system that you know
limits government that uses free markets
to allocate rewards and consequences of
behavior and one that's not overly
concerned with with income distribution
it doesn't it doesn't favor leveling and
that's in stark contrast to
european-style social democracy which
has a large and growing government which
believes in a managed economy and has as
its principal aspect something that is
big goal is making sure that people are
more or less equal and how much they
take from the economy at one point you
wrote the 30 percent coalition twists
equality of opportunity into equality of
outcomes they elevate money to the level
of justice by saying that this must be
equal to as Carl Marx famously put it
from each according to his ability to
each according to his needs
whereas President Obama put it almost as
famously when you spread the wealth
around it's good for everybody
isn't that
I mean from a persuasion from a
rhetorical perspective isn't that
inflammatory because it doesn't seem I
mean who are you speaking to there the
70% or the 30% so you do the 70% that
needs to stop losing arguments that
needs to stop losing arguments for what
they understand is true fairness look I
mean we've got yes who the 30% coalition
is before and I told you about the 5%
they're an idea industries there's
another 25 percentage points in there
and 15 of those percentage points are
young people who keep hearing fairness
fairness fairness and they love it
because fairness sounds really good and
the people on the political right or the
libertarians the the free-market here
you and me we get stuck talking about
economic efficiency so you know they'll
say well we want a fair system we'll say
but don't you understand that'll cut a
quarter percentage point off long term
economic growth rates and everybody just
yawns because these guys aren't even
paying taxes yet we need to be making
the moral argument and that means
actually stopping losing the arguments
about this basic concept of fairness
that that goes around all the time now
you said there is a fine line between
what one person sees is economic
equality and what others somebody else
sees is opportunity equality that's the
fight I want to have that's the argument
I want to have it if we look if
everybody in America agrees to repudiate
the idea of income equality right now
then let's then we'll have a deep fight
about what opportunity equality really
means and you know I can take that let's
talk a little bit about your kind of
personal ideology or intellectual
journal you were a professional musician
for many years you play the French horn
I did and all over the place didn't make
it quite through one year of college
when I was 18 but by a sort of mutual
conclusion of the College in me we went
our separate ways and I joined a chamber
music group and travel around the United
States visit all 50 states playing she
wasn't gonna join the Barcelona symphony
in Spain for several years who is your
favorite musician my favorite composer
and this is a hard thing to answer when
you're a classical musician right
because you've got the creators and
you've got the recreate errs right so I
go straight to the creators my favorite
composers Anton Bruckner and why is that
Anton Bruckner is he is the embodiment
of what was best in the Romantic period
building on everything that had come
before it that said if I have two
minutes to kill it'll always be a block
my Bach Bach because it's just right all
that
just right that sounds like the Outback
Steakhouse I don't know well I want to
thank Arthur Sze Brooks author of the
battle have a fight between free
enterprise and big government will shape
America's future also the president of
the American Enterprise Institute for
document reason TV today very much a lot
of fun
thank you